what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
do you have to decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in and the
forseeable feature
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
am recording this video from comic store
Ian's house yes I am I am recording this
video from his house I have finally made
it out to Colorado so spider-man is
getting his own movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe yes he's had his own
movies before he's had like five but
he's getting his own movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
spider-man homecoming it comes out this
weekend and to celebrate this momentous
occasion we're going to kill him because
that's what we do right like we kill
superheroes the Rob core is like the
most dangerous villain group ever in the
history of comic books we literally just
go around and try to find ways to kill
superheroes now as we do with each of
these videos we will start out with a
brief discussion of spider-man and his
powers to figure out why killing him
would be a challenge and then we'll move
on to our analysis of how we get taken
out permanently now unless you happen to
be watching this video
from a planet other than the planet
Earth I assume that you know who
spider-man is but in case you're
watching this from the andromeda galaxy
back in 1962 Stan Lee and Steve Ditko
created a character named Peter Parker a
high school student that got bitten by a
radioactive spider on a trip to a
science exhibition now as a result of
that bite Peter was given various
spider-like powers which we'll get into
later but after his Uncle Ben is
murdered he devotes his life to fighting
crime and became Marvel's most
recognizable superhero which is still
true today even over fifty years after
his creation now as far as spider-man's
powers go he has several powers that are
inherent to him as a result of the
spider bite and is also augmented those
abilities with several pieces of
technology that he's developed
throughout the years because in addition
to all the powers that were about to get
into Peter Parker's also a scientific
genius because why not
so first of all spider-man has
superhuman physical attributes including
strength speed durability agility
reflexes a healing factor and the
ability to like jump really far now in
terms of strength spider-man has
repeatedly demonstrated his ability to
lift multiple tons as he's been able to
pick up cars trucks tanks and has even
been able to support the weight of a
private jet and is held up the Daily
Bugle skyscraper as well as trying to
keep Soniya flow now as for how he's
able to use the
strength in battle spider-man's punches
would be absolutely devastating to his
opponents were not for the fact that he
is consistently pulling his punches so
that he does not dismember or even
killed him
I want to see that story I want to see a
story where Spiderman just like freaks
out one day right like spider-man kills
the Marvel Universe vitamins like I'm
had enough and I just starts attacking
people like he punches the lizard's head
off his shoulders and like rips off the
arms and legs and Doctor Octopus I'd
read it you know if I read ruins I can
handle that
if you guys didn't read ruins it's like
a worst case scenario in a story ever
it's like what would the Marvel Universe
look like if like everything that was
bad actually happened like it's a really
it's really really dark anyway
spider-man is made and even more
formidable foe by his insanely fast
agility and reflexes now his reflexes
are so fast that not only can he dodge
punches or melee attacks but he can even
dodge bullets so because of this dealing
damage to him is going to be difficult
but any damage that we are able to deal
is going to be of questionable
effectiveness because of Spidey's
increase durability and healing factor
now even though he isn't invulnerable
spider-man is much more durable than a
normal human and can heal faster than a
normal human as well although his
healing factor is nowhere near close to
other characters in the Marvel Universe
like will rain or Deadpool or The
Incredible Hulk
so while spider-man can take more damage
than a normal person
history bility and healing factor are
not going to be something that we have
to really gain play around since he can
be harmed by pretty much any
conventional means
now another ability that we have to take
into consideration is spider-man's
spider-sense which alerts him to
impending danger and allows them to
react to threats almost instantaneously
of course this is also the ability that
makes him one of the most capable
superheroes in the entirety of the
Marvel Universe
the spider sense operates as a tingling
feeling in spider-man's brain that
increases in intensity based on the
severity of the threat so of course the
more severe a villain is or the more
dangerous they are or the closer his
imminent attack is going to be the more
intense the spider sense this of course
is going to make killing spider-man even
more difficult because anything that we
plan he's going to be alerted to by his
spider sense before we can even
a bullet Adam much let's get close
enough to actually hit now in addition
to all this spider-man also has the
ability to wall crawl meaning he can
climb vertical services by clinging to
them with his hands and feet and can
even clean to services using only his
back so that pretty much wraps up
spider-man's actual powers but there is
one piece of equipment in spider-man is
used consistently over the years in his
own various comic books which we simply
just can't ignore as you've probably
guessed I'm referring to spider-man's
web shooters now everyone's probably
familiar with spider-man's ability to
swing across the city from webs
it's like the one thing I'm looking
forward to in his video game right like
this spider-man game I'm looking forward
to just like swinging around the city
I'll do that more than I then I go like
complete quests and go through the story
I'll just be like yeah spider-man but
anyway except for a brief period in
comic books spider-man's web shooting
ability is not a part of his power set
but instead comes from the web shooters
that Peter Parker invented shortly after
becoming spider-man now over time pier
has made modifications to the web
shooters themselves and has added
different cartridges capable of
producing different types of wedding
he's able to use the web shooters to
create webs that he can swing on to tie
up his enemies create nests strong
enough to hold back heavy vehicles or
shoot as a projectile weapon and so with
that in mind we can see why killing
spider-man is going to be a challenge
but nonetheless we do not give up so
it's time for us to move on to the
reason for why you click this video in
the first place figuring out how to kill
spider-man so I think the first thing
that we're going to have to do is take
out spider-man's spider-sense it makes
the most sense if we're going to kill
spider-man the last thing we want to
deal with is a spider since alerting him
to our attack the moment we launch it so
we need to find a way to negate it
fortunately for us there have been
several times when this has happened in
comics the Green Goblin once developed a
gas that not only doled Peter
spider-sense but all of his powers
Kraven the hunter was able to suppress
the spider sense with a jungle scent
Mysterio invented a device that was able
to neutralize the spider sense and Tony
Stark did something similar during the
Civil War storyline by inventing a
device that could confused spider-man by
sending out false signals it's also
possible that individuals with
telepathic abilities can disrupt
spider-man's spider-sense
and this is
and done at least one spy character
known as the rate now once the
spider-sense has been neutralized we're
still going to have to overcome his
other power so we need to ask ourselves
if there's any of spider-man's other
powers that we can eliminate and I think
the answer to that question is yes and
that I think we can negate spider-man's
ability to crawl up walls find a man's
wall-crawling ability can indeed be
completely neutralized
if the surface he's attending the climb
up is sufficiently slippery or
frictionless in fact such deal it's
villains like stilt man in paste-pot
pete have been able to use lubricants to
take away spider-man's ability to attach
himself to walls now while this might
not seem like a big deal I think that
taking away this ability is pretty
advantageous for us if we were able to
apply some sort of lubricant like the
chemical coating used by Alistair Smythe
which prevented spider-man's webs from
sticking to his original spider-slayer
robot if we were to find this chemical
and coat the entire area around our
fight with spider-man taking place we
can take away his ability to get to high
ground as you probably won't be able to
attach a web to a slippery surface
either that means that spider-man is
going to have to battle us on the ground
and even though he is still super strong
and super-quick and extremely durable it
makes our task infinitely easier if he's
not able to use the city landscape to
his advantage now even though we have
spider-man relegated to the ground we
still don't want to engage him and
hand-to-hand combat remember he could
dismember us with one punch and so we
need to find some weakness that he has
that we can use to our advantage to
level the playing field even more but
the question becomes does such a thing
exist in comics well believe it or not
it not only exists in comics but also in
the real world and we have to go all the
way back to amazing spider-man number
106 to find in that issue we once again
get a cue from Alistair Smythe
spider-slayer
this time the mark for version which
employs the chemical ethyl chloride
which spider-man says is home for the
spiders and since spider-man shares some
DNA with spiders he remarks now the
chemical lowers his body temperature and
slows him down so if we can acquire and
deploy a large amount of this gas we
might be able to slow down spider-man's
reflexes that combined with our
disruption of a spider sense and taking
away his wall-crawling and web-slinging
by applying a lubricant to the buildings
in the vicinity
we'll likely be enough to make
spider-man a sitting duck for any ranged
weapon that we want to employ meaning we
can basically take them out in any way
we want to we could use a machine gun we
could use a bazooka we could use a
grenade launcher we could hand it back
over to Sony almost anything that you
want in terms of how to take out
spider-man and just kill them off
forever but with that being said guys
we're going to go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here too
comments explained make sure you guys
with the sub button to become part of
the report if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and
leave a comment down below let me know
who you think we should kill next and I
will catch you all later
[Applause]
[Music]
you